hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my video all about what I think
they should be doing with the next
Suicide Squad movie there's definitely
gonna be a sequel eventually they're
gonna be using the characters in other
places Deathstroke probably one of the
biggest characters I think they need to
bring in so what's going on after the
movie well you know the strongest
performances obviously from some of the
biggest stars like Will Smith did a
great job as Deadshot very clearly gonna
continue to be a big thing in the DC
Universe same thing with Harley Quinn
and the Joker self explainatory pretty
much all the surviving members of the
Suicide Squad enchantra's like June moon
is still alive but I didn't really like
what Cara Delevingne did with her
character in the movie like her
performance so in the immediate future
as they plan what their next Suicide
Squad title is going to be I think that
they'll use some of these characters in
the other movies life has already been
rumors that the Joker has been spotted
on the set of Justice League it makes
sense that you would continue to use the
Joker just because Batman is such a big
presence in the DC movie universe so
hand in hand with that goes Harley Quinn
just because margot robbie was so
fantastic but because there's so much
going on in Justice League I think that
the Suicide Squad with in Justice League
will be a relatively small presence you
might get some awesome moments with
their characters but the main action of
the film is gonna be Ben Affleck going
around recruiting the Justice League
Steppenwolf and the forces of apocalypse
making their presence known
then fleshing out the mythology of the
mother boxes and Darkseid so there's
just so much that they still have to do
to develop the universe that I think if
they fast track any other movies that
are not Suicide Squad sequels with these
characters it'll be like an adaptation
of Batman mad love so it'll be somewhat
of a Batman story but mostly a story
about the origin of Harley Quinn
it'll just flesh out her relationship
with the Joker what's going on inside
her head how she thinks because if you
haven't seen my easter egg video that I
posted yesterday I talked about 10 or so
minutes of the Joker that was cut out of
the movie
so what those scenes were were mostly
scenes informing his relationship with
Harley Quinn and it seems like based on
descriptions of the stuff that they cut
out it's a more accurate portrayal of
the Joker's relationship with Harley
Quinn very abusive very toxic and if you
have seen Suicide Squad for the most
part the way Harley Quinn talks about
the Joker she really does love him
I feel like the next time you get like a
really deep dive into their characters
you'll see like Harley Quinn will
recognize what a toxic relationship it
is and she'll tell him to hit the bricks
which naturally he'll get really pissed
off about and they'll have a whole lot
of fun with Harley Quinn versus the
Joker
rather than painting them as
star-crossed lovers like the Suicide
Squad movie did so I feel like future
movies Harley Quinn vs. the Joker not so
much Harley Quinn in love with the Joker
but the most direct Suicide Squad movie
you know bad versus evil or bad guys
versus other bad guys would be like a
secret six type movie if you don't know
that secret six is it's a different team
Gail Simone had a nice run on it it's
just a bunch of other rogues from the DC
Universe that are put together an a-team
bunch of bad guys that are expendable
very in the vein of Suicide Squad so you
could do like a Suicide Squad versus
secret six type movie it invokes a lot
of checkmate which we haven't seen in
the DC Universe yet we've seen Argos but
checkmate is a completely different
organization but in the name of
everything being connected in this new
DC movie universe I think you'll see a
lot of things crossing over I would like
to see a Suicide Squad versus the
Justice League movie but I feel like
that's a long ways off that would be
like the third Suicide Squad movie like
they get marching orders we're supposed
to kill someone and then you get the big
surprise Batman Superman Wonder Woman
and the Flash's face come up on screen
and they all just poop their pants I
would like to see them do a Deathstroke
story that would be awesome for them to
include death stroke in the next Suicide
Squad movie do like a slightly different
version of Judas contract if you don't
know what that is it's really a Teen
Titans story so they could do like
Suicide Squad versus the Teen Titans or
invoke the Teen Titans in some way I
feel like the Teen Titans will exist in
the movie or somewhere they might just
be called the Titans they can totally
get there if they want to but right now
they're keeping things relatively simple
we have the Justice League we have
Suicide Squad and then as Amanda Waller
says there are evil people around the
world trying to grab their own
metahumans so I think if they're gonna
do something like hive like they're
gonna build an evil organization inside
the movie universe they would work
really well on the Suicide Squad story
too so really the thing that I'm hoping
they work up to is that the Suicide
Squad helps out during Justice League
and then you get the WTF twist where
they're ordered to kill the Justice
League on shadowy orders
is one of the best things and this does
come across in the Suicide Squad movie
where Will Smith is like you know what
if this all goes bad they're gonna blame
us for it we're all expendable they
don't care about us at all so Amanda
Waller is the biggest villain it seems
like she also isn't super hot on Batman
Bruce Wayne so it wouldn't be too
unbelievable for her to order a hit on
the Justice League like if she felt that
they were truly beyond her control and
she wanted to get rid of them but let me
know in the comments what do you want
them to do for the next Suicide Squad
movie assuming that it happens in like
the next two to three years and when do
you think that we will see more Teen
Titans in the movie universe I feel like
they could replace enchantress with
Raven and that would be like the back
door to Trigon and some other
supernatural things so they could
course-correct a little because I feel
like enchantress was a bit of a misstep
for the movie awesome character but not
so great portrayal so I feel like they
could bring Raven in that would be a
back door to Teen Titans all kinds of
awesome evil magical things and that
would be a backdoor to Batman family
Nightwing because I know everybody wants
to see Nightwing in the movies
eventually but it's probably gonna be a
couple weeks before you hear anything
about the next Suicide Squad movie just
because like it's making a boatload of
money now
the studio is typically like to wait a
little while to see how movies gonna do
before announcing what's gonna be
happening with the sequel so a lot of it
just depends on which actors they want
to bring back and it you know I feel
like most of the big stars of Suicide
Squad we're actually the best parts of
the movie so you know whatever they end
up deciding to do I feel like it'll be
good but just remains to be seen so if
there are any other Suicide Squad videos
you guys do want me to do or videos on
characters from the movie just let me
know in the comments there is a new
round of the DC giveaway that's going on
right now all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video so get hype and make sure you
go see Suicide Squad this weekend if you
haven't seen it yet what are you guys
wait for my next video to post you can
click here for all my Suicide Squad
Easter eggs you can click here to learn
all about Avengers infinity war and how
it's introducing Captain Marvel thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight